c'est un amboise que cinq personnes se
sont aperçus de larnack elle avait tout
retirer de l'argent aux mêmes
distributeurs
le mode opératoire des malfrats est bien
connu mais difficiles à repérer il fixe
une façade factice sur le distributeur
de billets qui leur permet de copier la
bande magnétique de la carte bancaire et
de filmer le code confidentiel
vous pouvez donc repartir avec votre
carte et vos billets sans vous
apercevoir de la manoeuvre
le malfaiteur peut quant à lui retiré de
l'argent sur votre compte avec une
fausse carte sur laquelle il aura copier
votre bande magnétique
le préjudice pour les victimes va de
quelques dizaines à des centaines
d'euros surveillez donc vos comptes si
quelque chose vous semblent suspects il
est possible que vous soyez victime
d'escroquerie à la carte bancaire